Yes.
All right, great. You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio.
[inaudible]
c. N. N. P. R. This is radio lab.
I'm Jad welcome to the podcast this week.
We've got an event to commemorate 104 years ago on a coldish blustery day in
North Carolina on the beach.
Two brothers figured out how to get a plane off the ground.
And because of this,
we can now take vacations in far away places we can, uh,
overnight packages to one another. But the,
the interesting thing is if you go back in time and you look at that moment,
you realize it was not inevitable. It didn't have to be that way.
Suppose that's true at any moment history. But in this one in particular,
and I'll just give you an example,
a German guy by the name of Auto Lillian Thall.
He would have been the first had it not been for, uh,
a Sunday in 1896 he tried to take off in his plane.
It soared for a beat and then nosedived and crashed.
He broke his back and story. Ghost is dying.
Words were sacrifices must be made.
Oh,
in the story, you're going to hear a lot of voices from uh,
the Smithsonian national air and space museum. A couple of experts,
some authors. And as it turns out, the great grand niece of Wilburn Orville.
Here it is.
There is something about being airborne, sort of an ethereal thing about it,
about leaving this earth thing you burst out on top of a few little clouds.
Freedom, gorgeous, bright sunlight control. It's beautiful.
Light is such a deeply held dream. Perhaps even in [inaudible].
Bye Bye. And my arrow. Bye.
Interesting to see how early the Wright brothers became interested in flight in
1878 when Wilbur is 11 and Orville is seven,
their father comes back from another church trip.
Their father was a bishop and I brought a president
for the some day when we own our own little helicopter,
there's a little helicopter toy. Ah, ah,
it was a little propeller. You know, you wind it up and let it go.
And the boys played with this. Yeah,
they played and played and that broke pretty quickly. Broke it.
And then instead of going on to the next toy, I guess as most kids would,
these guys began building their own version, experiment, Ting,
making their own designs. Look,
any airplane is going to be a complex machine that's made up of three systems,
four forces going to have to have wings,
dynamic lifts that will lift you into the air.
It's for us propulsion that will move you forward fast enough,
aerodynamic drag of resistance and you're going to have to have a way to control
this thing once it's in the air.
Now flight control was one issue
that almost nobody else had given any serious thought to.
Many of the folks that were also looking at this problem or are looking at
thrust and power sort of fell back on fat. Well,
if we just get a light enough engine,
then we can find and the Wright brothers right out of the bag did just the
opposite. The Wright brothers who are far more sophisticated,
Howard flight or anything like that, that could come later.
They decide to design and build a heavier than air flying machine that can be
absolutely controlled by the pilot. Every second it's in the air.
[inaudible]
control was the most important, um, aspect of this.
They watch the birds, they cited them a lot, the shapes of their wings.
Now when a turn of a bird would elevate a wing and dip the other wing,
increased the angle of attack on one side and decrease it on the other,
they were trying to find out, you know, how could we do that in a machine?
Uncle will he literally, it is a true story.
He was literally holding an inner tube box.
Wilbur was in the bike shop and he started moving the sides of the box,
twisting it back and forth and opposite direction and he realized that that was
it.
That's how you're going to achieve flight control.
Um, they could trip.
Then my air ship come take a trip around the star
and in the final version,
the pilot's laying prone on the lower wing with his waist in a cradle and he
shifts his weight to the right or left and that drags wire through the system
and puts a twist in the wing.
Come take a trip and my air ship will visit the man and the moon
grew up in the fourth level of the Franklin Institute.
And we have a storage area here.
Yeah,
this is a photograph. Um, maybe the, uh,
most recognizable photograph in the 20th century showing the first flight on
December 17th, 1903,
they're basically at the shoreline and then you can see the,
the ocean in the background here.
See the waves being picked up here,
a beautiful cold, crisp, clear day.
A lot of wind in there.
The reason why they're in North Carolina is because of the great winds.
10 35 in the morning,
they've set up their little rail that they run ne right flyer along a little $4
set of timber that they use as a launching mechanism. But like a sled,
there are no wheels to this plane. And they set up their flag,
which was assigned to the folks at the lifesaving station to come and help them,
uh, set airplane on the track.
They look the airplane over very carefully as he did on every flight that they
ever did. They'd flipped the coin and it was Orville's turn.
Orville got it on board before that,
they had had a moment of sounds where they shook hands when they started the
engines.
And this little airplane of Muslin and bicycle chains and spruce rumbled down
the track and took off.
Has it launches. Second Merkel occurs,
the man designated to snap the shutter on the camera does so precisely at the
point that Oroville breaks ground and is flying.
You can see it's maybe three or four feet off off the ground.
And here is Wilbur over on the ride running alongside of it. Yeah.
Goodwill ran along the right edge of one wing and held it steady.
Help steady it a bit and you can see his tracks in the sand and the s and the
famous picture or Valette only flown 120 feet and 12 seconds.
But on the last flight, the fourth flight, Wilbur flies 850,
two feet and 59 seconds. Uh, he's in the air almost a minute.
Well, they changed the world forever. I,
I can't think of anything that is, um, uh,
until the computer brought our world closer.
We went from determining distance in the miles between two places to determining
it in ours.
It was a vast accelerator of progress had they feel on December 17th and quit
flying,
flying with probably have been postponed by 10 years because at that moment in
time, the rights were fully 10 years ahead of everybody.
Now that at 10 years doesn't sound like a great deal until you factor.
In August of 1914, world war one began,
the French had about 140 airplanes. The British had about 180 airplanes,
German dead, about 250 airplanes.
They all had air forces that wouldn't have happened,
had rights not flown on that day at that moment.
But when you step back from that, even in a normal year,
10 million people will walk through the doors of the national air and Space
Museum. That's more people than go to the British Museum of the Lu.
They walk through the front door, that museum,
and there's the world's first airplane, the real thing,
and hanging right above it is the spirit of St Louis.
The first airplane to fly faster than sound.
That capsule in which John Glenn became the first American to orbit the earth.
People just look around and they say, wow.
Before Wilbur and Orville give really good here,
ordinary people in the streets say, if God had wanted us to fly,
you would given us wings
after the, what you hear people say is, if we can do that,
if human beings can do that,
okay,
can't we do the futures? Whatever anyone can dream.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
104 years ago this week,
the birth of flying that piece featured the voices of Tom Crouch,
who is the director of the national air and Space Museum. Walter Boyd,
who's the former director of initial air and Space Museum,
Dr Jane Palace in Aeronautical Engineer and leader of the right. Again,
project John LVD, senior curator at the Franklin Institute.
He's the guy at the picture and Amanda Right Lane,
who is a great grand niece of Wilbur and Orville. Right?
That's it for this week.
Radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
I'm Jad Abumrad. Thanks for listening.